all right guys bang bang got Darius here
with me Darius I thought a great place
for us to start this conversation is
probably in one of the most important
charts in global Finance which is global
liquidity we know that there's all sorts
of nonsense that's going on there's the
debt limit crisis there's inflation
there's the fed's comments there's
interest rates Etc but Global liquidity
seems to be driving a lot of asset
market movement and so what do you think
is happening with this Global liquidity
right now yeah absolutely and thanks for
having me back always a pleasure to be
with your audience man so I'll start by
saying we think the debt limit is sort
of the sealing whatever you want to call
it crisis or lack thereof is very much a
sale the news event and the reason we
think it's a sell the news event is
because the return of Uncle Sam I.E the
federal U.S government uh back to
International Capital Market that's
likely to drain a significant amount of
liquidity from the Global Financial
system so in this first chart we put up
here we show in the blue line the
statutory debt limit as approved by
Congress uh here in the U.S that
number's currently at
31.381 trillion dollars that's funny we
say the word t we throw the word t
around like it's uh like it used to be a
b but anyway so that number's at 31.38
trillion uh we are at the red line shows
the U.S debt outstanding that is subject
to that debt limit and as you can see
the red line and blue line have had the
same value for the better part of 2023
and um so that's one reason why we've
seen you know such positive asset market
performance uh the first half of this
year is because we have not had to
compete with Uncle Sam in terms of in
terms of all that liquidity demand for
all that liquidity and secondarily if we
look at the black line there in this
chart we show the treasury general
account balance which has declined all
the way from a ride around you know a
little bit a little bit over 800 billion
dollars you know a few months ago all
the way down to uh to 61. sorry not not
a few months ago a few quarters ago all
the way down to 61 billion that has been
a positive uh development for the global
liquidity cycle and it has certainly
been a supportive factor for why asset
markets have been taking this kind of
debt-selling Crisis if you will uh like
it's not really much like it's a walk in
the park explain what happens when all
of a sudden there's an uptick in
treasury bills right when uh the federal
government starts issuing these things
and we see this thing just tick up what
exactly do you expect to happen yeah so
actually that's a second chart we show
so we in the second chart uh we'll be uh
the title of the chart is a significant
uptick in t-bill issuance would actually
uh sterilize the pending rebuild of the
treasury Journal general account balance
so I'm sure most people know this but
for those of you who may be new to our
ecosystem and how we think about the
world you know the treasury general
account balance is one of the factors we
use in our adjusted liquidity model that
we're trying to kind of contextualize
you know the Ebbs and flows of liquidity
stemming from the interplay between the
public and private sector so the
treasury general account balance the
best way to think about that is sort of
the treasury you know the US government
the federal government's checking
account that it has on on balance on the
feds balance sheet and so that number
when it goes down It ultimately means
the treasury is taking money out of the
fence balance sheet and it's putting it
into the real economy either you know a
sort of a retiring debt uh vis-a-vis
principal and interest payments or
they're using that money to spend on on
Services
Etc in the economy and so it's basically
a net increase in liquidity when the
line goes down the line is about to go
up and go up in a major way in the
coming months if you look at the most
recent guidance that we got uh from the
uh from the treasury borrowing advisory
committee
um suggesting that you know this is not
this red line could be at 600 billion
dollars by the end of September you know
so that basically be bouncing off zero
you know so you're talking about a
significant increase in the amount of
money that the treasury is going to take
from the private sector to refill its
coffers on the FED balance sheet now you
asked a question about t-bill issuance
one thing that could actually make that
process a little bit less on risk for
markets is the fact that the treasury uh
if Jenna Yellen uh secretary yellin
decides to issue a significant amount of
T bills I.E instead of notes and coupons
these are shorter term shorter term
treasury debt Securities that mature in
less than a year there's a lot of excess
demand in that black line for those
particular types of Securities there's
about 2.3 trillion dollars in the
treasury or sorry 2.8 around 2.3
trillion dollars two point yeah uh three
trillion dollars in the uh feds reverse
repo facility balance now this is going
to get even more wonky and esoteric but
I'll just be quick that's basically
money market funds looking for t-bills
unable to find them so they're parking
that money on the fed's balance sheet
and earning the um earning the interest
uh they were earning right around 5.5
5.05 for that money so there's excess
demand for these Securities but she may
choose not to issue uh T bills and
there's a variety of reasons why we
think that so when you look at these
easing Financial conditions but
inflation running hot uh I think when it
begs the question like what actually is
inflation right now right you look at
trueflation that's down around three
percent you look at the official CPI
metric that's like 4.9 percent uh then
you have the question of like does that
actually get incorporated into whether
they're going to issue the T bills or
not uh I think as you point out in one
of these charts that Janet Yellen used
to actually run the Fed and so there's
some thought process around monetary
policy along with this debt limit crisis
and a depleting uh kind of balance for
the treasury how do you see uh Janet
Yellen uh kind of decision making
playing out here with uh quantitative
easing or some sort of financial easing
given inflation yeah that's a great
question so let's let's let's let's
summarize that and before we even unpack
the inflation in if Jenny Yellen decides
to issue a significant amount of t-bills
on the other side of the debt selling
which you know sometime around June 1st
to June 15th or so is likely when we're
gonna have to have that thing moved or
at the bare minimum punted into the
future she can choose to you know
replenish the coffers and then also
don't forget the government has a pretty
significant budget deficit of around
seven percent of GDP that they also need
to finance as well if they issue a bunch
of T bills they can drain the reverse
super facility balance down and tap into
that excess liquidity and make that
process somewhat smooth for asset
markets however if they choose to issue
a bunch of notes and coupons these are
interest bearing Securities that mature
a year or more up to 30 years currently
then that process is likely to be very
onerous or asset markets because we the
private sector are gonna have to come up
with funds to support that you know that
that data Insurance we're going to have
to sell stocks or sell other bonds or
sell Bitcoin or something to capitalize
the US government you know maybe not on
a one-form basis but certainly that's
kind of how it impacts the broader
private sector so going back to your
question on inflation and we sort of
have to ask put ourselves in Janet
yellen's seat to give a sense of why she
might choose to go one down one door or
into a door B and we we hypothesize that
because inflation is still running at
right around two to three x defense
price stability Target particularly when
you look at these measures of underlying
inflation on a three-month annualized
basis that it doesn't make a lot of
sense for her to support an easing of
financial conditions which would
coincide with the flooding of the market
with t bills and so um in this chart
here on slide three uh we show median
CPI trim mean CPI median PC inflation
trim mean PC inflation core PC inflation
which is the fed's preferred inflation
mandate and then Super core PC inflation
and all these numbers is at least two to
three x the FED price stability Target
on a three-month annualized rate of
change basis which is super important
because after you get past June we're
going to start to lose you know the kind
of the steepening of the base effects
that have been driven driving you know
year over year in price uh time series
down and in terms of inflation and we
might actually start to see a bottoming
process emerge in inflation time series
on a year-over-year basis as we head
into the back half of the year so it's
very unlikely in our opinion that Yellen
is incentivized to do anything that
would support you know asset markets and
s p going up Etc because ultimately what
that just means is it's going to
continue to Fan the Flames of inflation
in the US economy inverted yield curve
throws a another curveball in here what
uh what do you think that does yeah so
going back to this discussion on uh on
inflation you know we don't think Yellen
is sort of incentivized to be very kind
to asset markets you know in the in the
months and quarters following this debt
selling uh increase because ultimately
it means if she's if she's being kind
ass at markets she's ultimately being
very kind to the real economy which
would be very counter to the feds you
know stated objective of slowing the
economy causing pain in the economy so
that we can get inflation back under
control the yield curve this inversion
in the yield curve and it's a pretty
significant version one of the deepest
inversions we've seen you know going
back to the to you know the early 80s
this deep inversion of the yield curve
further disincentivizes her from
floating the market with t-bills because
again t-bills which are the shorter
maturity uh treasuries that you know
mature up to one year these have the
highest yields currently whereas if you
look at notes and bonds you know down
there kind of that's what this green
line shows in this chart here on slide
four you know the kind of the interest
rate across the curve from bills to the
left all the way to the bonds and notes
and bonds all the way to the right and
as you can see you know she's sort of
instead of advise that this particular
juncture to lock in lower coupons if you
kind of you know you know issue kind of
in the belly of the curve you know
somewhere right around three to ten
years and so the reality is just from
the cash map just from a from a from a
budgeting management standpoint because
obviously the treasury has to pay
interest on all this debt you know it's
from a budgeting management standpoint
it does not behoove her to concentrate a
significant amount of issuance which we
think according to our math could easily
be somewhere between 1 trillion and 1.4
trillion in the two quarters following
the debt selling tons of issues a
massive amount of issues that we have to
digest as from a market persistence
standpoint if she concentrates that
issuance at the top left of the chart
right here on slide four they were going
to have a problem as it relates to the
US government's um you know kind of
ballooning inversion and interest
payments so that's going to be another
issue from the perspective of asset
markets as well because again we don't
think inflation or the yield curve is
incentivizing her to make this rebuild
of the TGA and just general return of
debt issuance Ned devotion to support
the budget deficit uh to be a kind of a
row walk in the park kind of process
when central banks are uh injecting all
this liquidity into the market I think a
lot of times uh because we're so U.S
Centric we think so much about the
Federal Reserve uh we kind of think that
everyone's doing the same thing but
obviously we've seen q4q1 that at the
same time that the Fed was pulling all
this liquidity out of the market we saw
other central banks most notably in
Japan and China uh they were pumping
tons of liquidity into the market you've
got a chart here that shows that now
actually they may be done putting that
liquidity into the market are they just
running out of kind of dry powder are
they changing their stance what's
happening and why do you think that's
such a big deal yeah great question so
I'll start by just saying what is and
then we'll talk about why that may be um
so to your point uh yes so what I'm
showing in this chart here are the
balance sheets of the ECB here in slide
five uh the bank of England the bank of
Japan the people people think of China
and the Swiss National Bank these are
the kind of G2 through six central bank
balance sheets that kind of amalgamate
into our Global uh central bank balance
sheet a metric which also includes the
FED obviously um and that metric itself
feeds directly into our broader model
for Global liquidity which ultimately
includes Global narrow money supply as
well as Global foreign exchange reserves
but just focusing specifically on the
central bank balance sheet aspect of
that particularly through the lens of
the pboc and the boj we see that there's
been a significant inflection in these
balance sheets what I'm showing there in
the bottom panel on these charts is the
three-month impulse the trailing three
month momentum in each of these
indicators and as you can see in terms
of the black bars and the red bars you
know we had a pretty significant swing
higher from kind of the lows of late
2022 through the highs of 2020 um three
and both of those indicators you know
and you know at the highs of January of
2023 on a trolling through month basis
the bank of Japan's balance sheet was
expanding by plus 953 billion dollars
almost a trillion US dollars on a
trillion three month impulse basis that
number is now minus 173 uh billion
dollars uh pboc uh we had a pretty
significant impulse positive impulse and
in terms of its contribution to Global
liquidity uh you know kind of the early
product q1 as well that number peaked at
plus 853 billion dollars on a Charlie
three-month basis it's now minus 277 uh
billion dollars on a trail and three
month basis as well so you know these
numbers take time to kind of flow
through financial markets on a with a
little bit of a you know kind of a lag
but the reality is both of these central
banks if you go back and you look at the
reasons why they were so aggressive with
their monetary easing you know kind of a
couple of quarters ago it was because a
the bank of Japan was very much kind of
Defending yield curve control there's a
lot of speculative attacks in terms of
the market you know Market participants
speculating that they may change the
framework at some point now in the near
future and ultimately those attacks have
kind of Gone by the wayside in recent
months as we got because we will wait a
new bank Japan Governors come in and
pretty much doubled down on yield curve
control now I happen to think he's only
doing that to see setting up markets up
to surprise them later on this year but
the reality is those speculative attacks
have gone away and as as those
speculative attacks have gone away we've
seen the bank of Japan's willingness or
even need to supply the market with a
ton of liquidity has gone away as well
looking at the pboc obviously you go
back to late fall you know China was
real struggling to get off the ground as
a as a function of zero covet finally
got the relaxation of that that
regulatory policy and ultimately we saw
the pboc you know really kind of stepped
its put on the gas pedal to get that
recovery started uh particularly in the
context of what ultimately turned out to
be very muted fiscals report in China so
it's pretty clear from our perspective
that a the signals that we're seeing
from the fiscal fiscal authorities in
China I.E very limited fiscal support
and also in terms of the growth Target
that they announce in uh back in March
for a full year of 2023 that it's
unlikely that we need to see the pboc
very aggressively supporting the Chinese
economy over the near term now that may
change if their recovery starts to
wobble as we think it already has
started to in the coming months but
certainly it's unlikely we're going to
see anything like what we saw you know
kind of heading into the early part of
this year so if Global liquidity
specifically coming from these central
banks is not linear there's variation to
it sometimes uh one or two of them are
pumping liquidity sometimes others are
draining it sometimes even the same
Central Bank as we're talking about here
uh can go from pumping in liquidities to
taking it out uh why are asset prices
trading I think as you point out as if
Global liquidity has now kind of
bottomed and we're just going to go up
and there's going to be more and more
liquidity in this linear fashion yeah
well that's that I think that's part of
the narrative machine right you know we
certainly uh live in a kind of a
narrative driven world you know as
connected as you've ever been and there
is this sort of narrative out there that
you know liquidity is going to continue
ubiquitously improving now I don't I I
very much agree with that narrative on a
longer term time Horizon you know 18
months from now global liquidity will be
way higher than it is currently maybe
even 12 months from now but I think
inside of 12 months from now you have to
consider the path that it's going to
take to get there and the reality is
asset markets are currently pricing a
very linear path to getting Global
liquidity much higher 12 18 24 months
from now um so what I'm showing in this
chart here on slide six is our Global
liquidity proxy as I mentioned that is
the sum of the global central bank
balance sheet which includes the fed the
ECB the bank of England bank of Japan
People's Bank of China and swiss
National Bank that also includes Global
narrow money supply which is the sum of
the narrow money supply in each of those
economies as well as Global FX reserves
uh minus goal and so when we were taking
we would track them we amalgamate those
three statistics you know that's the
blue line and the top panel there the
blue line and the second panel just
shows the one year Z score of that
particular indicator and as you can see
it's a minus 0.7 Sigma so that's kind of
where we are in terms of on a normalized
basis in terms of global liquidity uh in
terms of looking at on a trailing one
year look back when you apply that same
study to Global Equity market cap which
is the red line in the chart or Bitcoin
for instance which is the black line of
the chart we see that you know those
those uh one year Z scores for those two
indicators are plus 1.1 and plus 1.2
respectively and so very clearly we've
seen the recovery and asset markets
outpace the recovery in global liquidity
now that may be the case that asset
markets just got a little bit ahead of
themselves and Global liquidity is about
to catch up or it could be the case that
asset markets got a lot ahead of
themselves on this Sort of hope and
expectation that the blue line was going
to you know linearly continue improving
without even considering you know some
of these uh post-dead selling dynamics
that we're talking about in the US and
some of these other Central Bank about
balance sheet dynamics that we talked
about in in Asia with the views like in
China and Bank of Japan
when you see uh kind of the United
States debt limit talks let's bring this
all the way back home
um and it seems like all the attention
is there the inflation number headline
at least is coming down do you
anticipate that we will get recession
that we will get quantitative easing
that we will get a pause like how do you
look at the monetary policy and the
actions of the Federal Reserve over the
next let's call it uh 90 days or so in
light of kind of the air being sucked
out of the room on this whole debt limit
thing isn't really a monetary policy
thing right it's not it's not something
that the FED is actively involved in or
should be involved in and so it seems
like you ever seen the meme where
there's the three people and it's like
the feds in the background and then the
person's looking at the treasury right
like that's literally what's happening
right now it's like what's going on in
the back what's going on with the other
person right what's the FED going to do
over the next 90 days in your opinion
yeah great question man look and this is
why we talk about all the stuff all at
once you know it's you know trying to
you know one this whole concept of
global liquidity is a very kind of
squishy concept so you need to you I
think what we do at 40 to macros is try
to do a very you know institutional
level job of trying to amalgamate this
stuff and keep track of it you know in
the way that you would if you're sitting
in a by side chair and so you know
you're going back to answering your
questions specifically as it relates to
the fed the FED is in our opinion very
much engaged in the monetary policy
policy as it relates to its interest
rate policy one thing that we have not
talked about at all because it hasn't
been relevant in 2023 is their balance
sheet because the federal government has
not been issuing debt on a net basis
particularly coupon debt which you know
kind of drains more liquidity from from
the private sector than t-bills uh given
the reversible facility balance because
we've not been issuing that coupon debt
for basically since January quantitative
tightening has had no bite it has not
drained Bank Reserves if those
Securities have just rolled off the feds
balance sheet and we the private sector
did not have to fund the next round of
issuance for the from the from the
treasury because there was no next round
of issue been at the statutory deadline
this is January once we get past the
statutory debt limit I.E either it's
removed or it's punted into the future
in terms of the Continuum resolution we
are going to not we the treasury will
start to issue debt again and so that
ultimately means that that quantitative
tightening process that we expect the
FED to continue to be engaged in at
least into the recession is very clear
and evident in the labor market uh just
given the kind of dynamics that we
expect to see in inflation over the next
few quarters until you know that the
return of this debt issuance is going to
cause quantitative tightening to start
draining Bank Reserves from the Global
Financial system again which ultimately
means the asset markets from a liquidity
perspective when you think you tie in
the FED back to the treasury and
ultimately lay around some of these um
foreign central banks et cetera some of
the moves that we're seeing there
it's very likely that we go back to
liquidity conditions that look very much
like 2022. now will they be as bad or as
negative as they were in 2022 that's the
unlikely however you know from this
particular starting point from a you
know very rapidly forming investor
consensus around this kind of ubiquitous
expectation for you know kind of a
linear recovery in global liquidity I
think you're you know we're probably
setting up for for at least two perhaps
in as long as four to six months of you
know kind of um you know 2022 like you
know liquidity conditions which are
obviously not very good
as we look into debt limit crisis kind
of off of the uh Cliff if you will are
you doing anything different in your
portfolio
uh debt limit no I mean we're pretty
deep risk as you know we run a
systematic uh um risk management process
in terms of our portfolio construction
ideas and and pivots and so that process
is you know north of 50 cash you know
very limited exposure uh to fixed income
markets in fact the the asset class that
we have the most exposure to currently
uh is in the equities but it's still you
know kind of de minimis relative to uh
it's you know it's made in max range so
you know I don't think you need to be
trading as an investor the debt ceiling
itself I think the bigger trade the more
structural overhanging on our asset
markets is what we've been talking about
for the last 20 minutes which is we're
going to go from this very very positive
six-month period in liquidity conditions
two at the bare minimum a somewhat bad
period over the next let's call it two
perhaps four months that somewhat bad
period could be very bad depending on
the composition of debt uh and the speed
of debt issuance that uh the treasury
Department elects to pursue uh in the
coming months so it's not going to be a
good Summer from our perspective for the
perspective of taking risk in asset
markets is this the beginning of the big
bang that we've expected uh you know
kind of um as it relates to the U.S
recession process that in our opinion is
lucky to spill over to the global
economy I don't think so I think we're
probably going to get you know nasty set
of market conditions over the next few
months markets will probably find some
some some low there rally towards you
know Q4 maybe even into year in and
that's probably it for this Market Tech
working with some people to find you or
find out more about 42 macro I
appreciate you pop so uh definitely come
check us out 42 macro obviously you know
we tend to cater to uh professional
investors institutional investors
without research but we also have plenty
of research uh products and and services
for you know retail investors crypto
investors you know I like to think that
you know what we're trying to do is help
regular everyday investors weaponize
their risk management with the same kind
of information that we use you know we
you know we can you know we contribute
to um to the brightest institutions on
global Wall Street
I always appreciate talking to you and I
learned something I think every single
time today I learned multiple things
which means it's a great day so I
appreciate you coming on and uh and
doing this and we'll do it again in the
future
absolutely brother I appreciate you